the jurogan experience and then so uh
but my friend was like yo how you gonna
start doing stand up i was like i don't
know man maybe i'll start doing like
some clown stuff or something like that
i was like
maybe like 15. i was like maybe i'll
start doing like some clown stuff or
something
oh yeah and i heard about like a clown
school in san francisco
and i was like oh yeah maybe maybe i'll
do that and then that didn't happen and
the friend was
like once you just go to like an open
mic or something like that i was like oh
is that how you get started and i was
like all right then maybe i'll do that
but like fast forward i had a lot of
time on my hands
uh back in 2018. i wasn't doing [ __ ] and
i was at the like
man i was like [ __ ] you should take a
class i was like you're already in the
wave you already does like he's gonna
take a class
whatever so i took a clown class and uh
it's called the clown school i'm like on
their website and [ __ ] i'm like the only
[ __ ] i'm like the only black people
like on their website and [ __ ]
and uh i just started doing it in 2018
and um it you know what's so fun about
that
is that like if you didn't know what
made you funny as a person
or whatever like they help you find like
your inner clown
you know you know what i'm saying
everybody has an inner clown and stuff
like what's first day of clown school
like
so so i i remember i remember this uh i
remember this assignment first of all i
walked in there with some doc martens on
right i
they were they were maroon doc martens
they look like um
they look like clown shoes but they were
maroon doc martens and the
clown teachers that they're like hey
take those off
and i was like why he was like just take
him off and then it
dawned on me i was like i was probably
disrespecting clown because he probably
thought that that's what i thought a
clown was
whatever people who wear shoes like this
because doc martens do kind of look like
you know clown shoes if you whatever and
then so uh
just plain no but i i i i dawned on me i
was
like that's probably why you really
think you thought it was disrespectful
to clown to the whole art of clown or
whatever he was like oh you think clowns
just wear big shoes and
get out of small cars that would be fun
that would be a funny sketch dude
a guy who teaches clown classes but he's
like really sensitive
about the art of being a clown and he's
a purist he's a clown purist
yeah what do you got a rubber nose on
get that [ __ ] nose off
so it's so [ __ ] funny right it's like
um
i remember the first assignment though
was uh hey
come through this door 10 funny ways
and i was like i was like oh that sounds
funny so i mean so that sounds fun so i
was just coming out
do like a physical act with her but i
would do it 10 funny ways i would come
in as a robot and i would come in as a
did you ever come through naked
you should take that class and then you
should do that what's
up now but you know what they don't
limit [ __ ] like that though like if you
wanted to do some [ __ ] like that because
they want you to be free
got it yeah so i remember i remember
that assignment come through this door
10 funny ways
what did you do um so i came in like i
came in like crawling and [ __ ] like that
and then i came in like [ __ ] and
[ __ ] like that
i came in i came in spinning like this
or whatever
and i remember i like hopped backward
like a kangaroo and [ __ ] like that and
it was a it wasn't much [ __ ] like that
what did other people
what were they like what were the other
people in the class like some
[ __ ] in there were good
like because because the thing about
clown is like
is that they they say like the the wrong
answers
are what's funny so you know like if you
come in
if you come in if you come in or
whatever and you accidentally trip and
[ __ ] like that like it was an accident
yeah that's what the clown is the clowns
are the mistakes
and stuff like that and you know the red
nose is
actually uh is actually just puts you in
the spirit of
being a clown and being silly but but
the maroon
doc martens don't exactly exactly
you know what that's like that's like a
bad stand-up coach giving you advice on
stand-up
because that that has happened to a lot
of people catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience